so if you were actually going to try and
become batman there's a few things that
would prevent that from working it's
wholly impractical but one of the main
things is probably that bad knee you
keep putting your ankle out whatever the
case most of us have a couple of
injuries that we've picked up along the
way in the dark knight frank miller's
graphic novel we see an older batman
who's retired following the death of his
robin of course he's dragged back into
action he takes back to the streets and
kicks some serious ass the question is
how feasible how realistic is this how
can we train in such a way to have
longevity so that we can keep jumping
and lifting and throwing and sprinting
even as we get older a lot of us think
that age is inevitable and that we are
going to lose the ability to move and to
do all the things we love but i
personally don't believe that to be the
case so in this video we're going to
discuss how to train like the dark
knight
so our nemesis here the enemy is someone
far more insidious than the joker or mr
freeze the evolutionary shadow describes
the fact that once you reach a certain
age you've either procreated or you
haven't and as far as evolution is
concerned that's it you've either passed
on your genes or you haven't and what
happens after that point has no impact
on future evolution of the species
therefore after a certain age we are
allowed to just fall apart and this
isn't going to factor into our overall
survival as far as natural selection is
concerned that's why we see a lot of the
degradation and the breakdown that we're
dealing with here but again fortunately
the body is built in such a way that
there are methods we can use to combat
this and slow it down i'm actually
filming today at a gym called first
fitness in vista which is run by paul
clutterback and he's very kindly let us
film here and he's going to show us a
move or two as well whilst we're here
i'm also here with liam ellis
parkour extraordinaire you've seen him
on this channel before he's also a
fantastic videographer and if you guys
should need any videography he is
available perception media i'll put a
link in the description down below and
he too is going to be demoing a few
moves during this video
so what's going on here well for
starters of course we have sarcopenia
once you reach a certain age it's hard
to put on muscle mass and they're not
going to be as big however we also have
dynapenia this is the fact that your
muscles are less strong and actually the
dinopenia is greater than the sarcopenia
alone suggests that is to say that the
muscles are still big enough to be
stronger than they actually are which
means we know there's some other stuff
going on here this likely includes such
things as tendons your tendons probably
get weaker and more compliant which
we'll talk about in a moment as well as
neural drive your neural drive decreases
it's hard for you to recruit those
muscle fibers and exert as much force at
the same time your bone density
decreases resorption starts to outpace
formation meaning in other words that
you're losing bone density faster than
you're able to rebuild it so they become
weaker you're more likely to break your
bones of course testosterone falls this
is gonna make you less anabolic makes it
harder to recover as we age of course we
also see a reduction in quality and
quantity of mitochondria mitochondria of
course being the power plants of the
cell they provide us with energy and as
these deplete we become far less
energetic and more tired and then you
have dna damage over time telomeres
exist at the end of your dna strands
every time a cell reproduces and your
dna is copied you lose a little bit of
that telomere telomeres act as buffers
and once they're gone you start to eat
into actual dna and this is where you
start to see all kinds of things go
wrong some of the visible signs of aging
at the same time of course we just have
regular wear and tear the longer you're
alive the more accidents you like to
have the more like you are to twist an
ankle too badly and these sorts of
things build up over time especially if
we don't treat them properly at the time
which is again something we're going to
talk about in a moment and even your
brain function starts to decline as you
get older as we know you'll lose fluid
intelligence which is your ability to
think quickly on the spot although
crystallized intelligence that is
knowledge actually remains at the same
time brain plasticity will often be
reduced now we used to think that brain
plasticity stopped entirely after a
certain age however we now know that it
is still possible to grow new neural
connections and even birth new brain
cells late into older age the problem is
once again our lifestyles often don't
support this good news is that whilst we
do see reduced brain plasticity there
are lifestyle factors that play a role
in this and we can increase it and one
of the most important ways to increase
brain plasticity is to learn more the
more you learn the more you keep trying
new things the more you produce those
neurotransmitters and the more plastic
your brain remains and this explains so
much about why we lose mental sharpness
and lose movement ability as we get
older babies have slightly different
brains they go through a lot of pruning
but in general when you're learning new
things when you're first born when
you're very young
everything is new even your ability to
see contrast is something that's foreign
alien to your brain so is it any
surprise that your brain is absolutely
awash with these chemicals that make
learning so easy for children then as we
get older we continue to learn a lot
children of course have to learn more
social skills they learn things at
school they might start a new hobby or a
class and this continues even as we're
teenagers and into young adulthood you
might learn to drive we learn new jobs
have new relationships move to different
parts of the world
as you get older still things start to
slow down you've learned to drive this
is no longer that novel for your brain
you've found a job that you like and you
go to that workplace every single day
and do pretty much the same thing in the
evenings you come home and relax on the
sofa because you're feeling tired partly
due to that lack of bdnf etc and we just
learn less and less
compounding this then is any aches and
pains any injuries that make it harder
for us to go out and do new things we
become more tired and for all these
reasons the brain becomes significantly
less plastic we hear things like you
can't teach an old dog new tricks
when it comes to learning new things one
of your best options is skillshare which
also just so happens to be today's
sponsor skillshare is a platform for
learning that has thousands of classes
and members across 150 countries what
makes skillshare different though is
that these classes are made by members
of the community making this a truly
crowd-sourced learning experience for
the budding poly i actually have been
using skillshare myself for years and i
used it for example to learn how to make
3d models in a combination of blender
and unity and to animate them so if you
like any of the cgi that you've seen on
this channel that's actually how i made
it i even made a few 3d prints like this
a great class to get started with is
your first day in blender 3d from
southern shotty 3d skillshare is
completely ad-free there are new premium
classes every week and the entire back
catalogue is now available with
subtitles in spanish french portuguese
and german so if you're interested in
levelling up your learning then check
out skillshare using the link below and
the first 1000 people to use the link
will get a one month free trial of
skillshare thanks again to skillshare
for sponsoring this video thanks to you
guys for watching and on with the show
and in terms of learning i'm not just
talking about sitting in front of a book
and reading
the best kind of learning for the brain
is moving in 3d space this creates so
much information for the brain from the
proprioceptors to the equilibrium
scepters to your vision so much
information coming at the brain all at
once and you having to adjust your
movement accordingly this fills the
brain awash with brain plasticity
enhancing chemicals and as a result if
you keep doing this you'll keep your
brain healthy and young so learn new
skills whether it's parkour whether it's
rings whether it's hand balancing
whether it's running keep learning new
things keep moving your body in new ways
and you'll keep your brain active and
young as well as your body same time
moving in more ways and more vectors is
also really good for your fascia the
connective tissue that surrounds the
muscles and joints if you look at the
work of thomas myers his anatomy traits
he explains how if you train only using
the same linear movements all the time
you can strengthen specific lines of
fascia whilst the neighboring areas can
become brittle and weaker the wider
variety of movements you use the more
resilient you'll be the more mobile the
thing is far too often people act as
though we have a set number of joint
uses like you can wear out your knees or
your elbows obviously the body doesn't
work like that and more often what we
think of as overuse injuries or you know
just wear and tear is actually either
under recovery or it can be imbalanced
that is to say that you might have
trained one side of your body too much
and not the other very often for example
we can see elbow issues if you do a lot
of curls because you're using your
forearm flexors and not the extensors
for this reason you need a wide variety
of movements once again
in general though strength training
resistance training is fantastic not
only for preventing and slowing down
sarcopenia
much older people can still experience
hypertrophy it also builds bone density
curling weights or squatting it's a
fantastic way to build stronger bones
reduce the likelihood of osteoporosis
and prevent breaks and other issues of
course it's also strengthening the
tendons in lieu of adding resistance
impact can have a similar effect for the
bones for example studies show that
sprinting builds stronger bones than
does jogging now of course as you're
getting older and picking up injuries
you don't just start sprinting and
leaping off of boxes and therefore
you're going to want to ease into this
slowly but notice how a lot of this is
the stuff that we've been told not to do
that we assume we shouldn't do as we get
older truth is this is the very stuff in
the right dose that prevents you from
injuring yourself
what also decreases as you age is neural
drive your ability to recruit muscle
fiber however this doesn't start to
decline until the age of 55.
pro tip if you're going to use medicine
balls you're not familiar with make sure
you know just how much they bounce
before you slam them on the ground
so if you're an expert martial artist
you've been training your entire life
you're going to maintain a lot of that
power even as you get older because you
have the perfect technique and you can
recruit the muscle fiber this might
contribute to what we call old man
strength because you're continuing to
improve those neural pathways as you get
older and older thereby increasing your
strength up to this age of about 55 and
then of course it doesn't just
immediately drop off this goes double
for labourers and anyone who uses
particular movement patterns very often
if you've ever felt the grip of your dad
when you're a kid it probably felt like
a vice this might be partly why however
past this age of 55 we do start seeing
drop off we also start to see greater
activation of the antagonist muscles in
other words your movements become
slightly less coordinated and you slow
yourself down in terms of mitochondria
the best thing you can do to hang on to
them as long as possible is to
incorporate a little bit of high
intensity interval training into your
workouts high intestinal training has
been called by some of the fountain of
youth because of its ability to
replenish mitochondria keep them there
keep them healthy just remember that
mitochondrial density can be domain
specific that is to say that just
because you're sprinting doesn't mean
your arms aren't losing mitochondria so
get a wide range of different metabolic
finishes to incorporate into your
training
and the missing piece of puzzle might be
tendon strength because of course tendon
injuries become more likely as we get
older and according to the most recent
research we do indeed not only become
more likely to tear a tendon they also
become more compliant and in this case
that's not a good thing we're not
talking about flexibility here we're
talking about slack so that when you try
and exert force on a joint actually
takes longer for the muscle to transfer
that force to the joint because it's
like pulling on a rope rather than a
steel cable our tendons are capable of
withstanding a lot more pressure and
force than our muscles and so one of the
best ways to train for stronger tendons
is to apply a lot of resistance and use
a wider range of motion however this is
something to talk about in a second if
you're someone who currently is already
experiencing tendon issues if they're
not as strong as they could be then
instead we want to focus on getting
blood supply to the area we know that
tendons have limited blood supply
compared to muscles and they take longer
to respond to training so you want to
use lots of high repetition pump work to
try and strengthen them as much as
possible and it's talked a lot about by
keegan smith check out his youtube
channel the atg coach he discusses short
range strength and long range strength
and short range strength is what we're
interested in first because this means
using shorter range of motion whether
your muscle is shorter in order to pump
lots of blood we're going to use lighter
resistance higher rep ranges and we're
going to fill those tendons with blood
in order to help encourage them to
recover and to get stronger so they
don't get hurt in the first place
so for this you can use lots of
movements that have a short range of
motion or that are causing almost muscle
cramp whether in that shorter range even
like an l-sit or a v-sit where you're
cramping the muscle up together at the
same time once you've built that
resilience the atg group they then move
on to movements that have a much longer
range of motion
so this is an atg pull down
or a very good exercise to get full
range of motion full lengthening of the
lats at the back there which can
actually work towards doing your full
range pull up pulling it into your chest
so gonna select your weight sit on the
floor
backhand down let that
pull you all the way up
and as you pull down
pull it right into your chest
and then control all the way back up
again again getting that full
lengthening in the lats
pull all the way down
control all the way back up again and
this is designed to increase the amount
of tension on the connective tissue
because now you're not only adding the
amount of resistance that your muscle is
capable of exerting but also the
additional momentum and gravity that is
caused by going to that full extreme
range of course we don't need to go to
this point if we're just trying to age
gracefully but if we were batman we're
trying to get the very most of our
tendons in old age this might be one way
to go so thanks a ton for watching this
video guys if you liked it then please
leave a like and share it around that
helps me out immensely if you enjoy this
kind of training that focuses not just
on strength and aesthetics but on things
like mobility brain function endurance
then you'll enjoy my ebook and training
program super functional training 2.0
the protein performance system that also
comes with over two hours of
instructional video you can check out in
the link in the description down below
either way thank you so much for
watching this one guys and i'll see you
next time
bye for now